Hi, I’m Evan Carmichael.
Welcome to another edition of Ask Evan.
In today’s episode I’m going to answer a question from Freddyca
who’s one of my newsletter readers who wrote in asking
about the business plan.
So she wrote saying
“I have a business plan prepared
and I’d like some tips from you to help me prepare.”
So thanks for the question Freddyca.
Exciting times, planning a new business is really good.
I’m happy for you.
In terms of the business plan I’d think about;
are you planning the business plan for yourself
or are you creating it for an investor
or banker to give you money?
From an investor point of view
when I was in the venture capital field
what we looked at when a new business plan came in
and we rejected 99% of the business plans that came in
but what we look for first was the Executive Summary.
So, you know, quickly in two pages
explain why this is a good opportunity.
If you can’t sell them on those two pages
then they’re not going to read the rest of the business plan.
So that’s got to be really solid to start.
We always start there.
Then we look at the team
and look at who is this behind the company.
So have they had experience
have they done it before
do they think they have a good chance of being successful?
You know, if it’s just you you might want to consider
getting some advisers on the company as well
to add a little more credibility
who’ve maybe gone through it
have a little more experience than you.
And then we go look at the financials and see
is this an opportunity to make money
do we think they’re going to be able to give us
a return on the investment that we’re putting in.
So that’s how we would start:
Executive Summary, Management, then financials,
and then we look at the rest of the business plan.
And most of the time the entrepreneurs would fail
on one of those three and they would end up, you know
getting deleted or rejected.
So that’s what’s happening
if you’re going to go for investors or bankers.
If it’s for your own self
if it’s going to be to help you guide
and plan your business
I would start with
what is it that really excites you about your business,
what’s the vision that you have for your company
you know, what gets your blood pumping
when you wake up in the morning
to pursue this business opportunity?
So create that vision statement, you know
what you’re here to do and major goal for the company
so long as it’s going to get you excited every day.
And then from there start working out
how you’re going to make that happen.
So you know, what kind of marketing do you need to do
who are the people that you need bring on
what kind of, you know, finances do you need
to have in place to make it work
and how are you going to
phase that out over a period of years
if you’re doing a 3 year plan or 5 year plan.
Just make sure it makes common sense.
You have to come back to your business plan
on a regular basis to update it, to, you know,
reflect the market changes that you’re seeing.
The business plan never goes according to plan
but it’s still a good process to go through
and to keep monitoring and updating.
So I hope that helps.
Two different bits of advice depending on
if you’re going to use it yourself
or if you’re going to use it to go out and get funding
but if you have extra questions feel free to leave it below.
For those watching
if you like the video please give it a thumbs-up.
It makes me want to create more of these videos for you guys
and if you have a question about business plan
or if you have some advice for Freddyca as well
feel free to leave it in the comments underneath.
I always love seeing those too.
And we’ll see you on the next episode!